foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'll
I'll
start a state and scream at your service
[Music]
baby we started pretty small but take a
look at us now take a look at us now
suddenly it's starting Ten Feet Tall
take a look at us now take a look at us
now though we had no way
[Music]
[Music]
at the top of the world tonight
[Music]
there is behind
[Music]
at the top of the world tonight if you
stay this way as East until the morning
life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at the top of the world
[Music]
the top of the world tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop resting up the recipe
let go of how it has to be
Let's Dance Mom
[Music]
[Music]
that is an ambulance
that was a car tire
what was that
I have no idea what that was
New York City did we just move here if
we did you think Josh is gonna be okay
this is my crocodile please take good
care of him
oh gosh time to wake up come on
he's not dangerous
dial he's just lonely like me hey you
awake yet you can't talk but you can
sing at the top of the world tonight
when no one ever
get out of here there's a crocodile in
the house
[Music]
all right
that was totally awesome
the city must do something
do you realize how different things have
been since I met him
you changed everything for me not just
for me for YouTube
item we have to show people that they
don't have to be afraid
oh you got a crocodile on a motorcycle
[Music]
come on
there's a crocodile in the house oh
hello you must be the new tenants like
to prevalently on your service I see
you've met my crocodile he's an
extraordinary Talent his name is Lyle
[Music]
mom I swear to you he's not dangerous
he's a crocodile okay yes crocodiles can
bite through boning yes they have a
taste for human flesh but he's not like
that he wears a scarf
and he can sing
[Music]
are you sure this is safe oh what's safe
we're here to live and living is a
dangerous business
laughs
that was awesome
you can find
something somewhere left behind
if you stay this way at least until the
morning
[Music]
it's his first time in a taxi
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you